okay let's update a story from earlier
this week on Monday I announced that big
changes were coming to the David Pakman
show because YouTube is over the YouTube
ad pocalypse is basically here to stay
I've been having a lot of conversations
Pat Pat's drinking something over there
which is making what drink is actually
no don't even tell you what drink it is
or much controversy it's not it's not a
spot we don't want to give free
publicity to any any of those weird
drink companies if you only saw what Pat
had over there you would be appalled let
me tell you that
anyway YouTube is basically over okay
YouTube ad pocalypse I spoke to a lot of
people over the break we cannot expect
any kind of recovery to anywhere close
to the YouTube revenue that we used to
have so we're going to continue
publishing to YouTube we have a sizable
audience there close to 400,000
subscribers millions and millions of
monthly views but we're really going to
start growing the extra content on other
platforms including through membership
and patreon now on membership we
estimate and it's not really an estimate
that is difficult to make we just know
that a tiny tiny fraction of our
audience are members but our retention
rate on membership is huge in other
words when people do become members they
tend to stay members because membership
comes with really great ways to consume
the show so on Monday I mentioned we'd
be doing dollar trial memberships that
is now happening okay you can go to
david pakman.com slash dollar you spell
it out DOL lar and you get a one-week
membership for $1 okay it is a full
membership it is not as limited features
you only get blah blah blah you get a
week of full membership for $1 if you
then want to continue you can either do
it for the normal rate of 6 dollars per
month but you can also stop the trial
membership and then sign up with the 40%
discount code of I voted 17 or you can
switch to a yearly membership whatever
right but the deal is david pakman.com
slash dollar it is $1 for a week
membership you will love it folks
believe me it is absolutely fantastic
you're starting to sound a little bit
like oprah winfrey you get a membership
you get a membership it's just so
accessible at this point it is and I
know that it's annoying that the 1
dollar membership is connected
to a $6 membership when there are other
membership options
it's just how our system works any trial
membership needs to morph into some
other membership in our system so I set
it up with the cheapest one and you can
still use a coupon code if you decide
after the dollar trial you want to keep
it so david pakman.com slash dollar also
patreon supporters soon will be able to
get the bonus show and the full
commercial free TV show at different
support levels that is happening soon we
have targets set up for 2,000 3,000 and
4,000 patrons we're gonna be adding
reward tiers at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and many many other things
very important things serious things are
upcoming but for now the big revelation
is david pakman.com slash dollar one
week one dollar trial membership